are you ready for witch-hunt 2.0 get
ready because that's what the Democrats
are gearing up for after mother's
testimony failed to deliver the knockout
blow to Trump's presidency that they
promised Nancy Pelosi and her pals are
now revealing their new plans to go
after Trump we are filing an application
for the grand jury material underlying
the Mulla report we will continue to
seek testimony and keep facts witnesses
and to investigate the president's
misconduct and it was clear to me anyway
yesterday he did not follow the money so
someone needs to do the investigation
into money laundering
we're having a vigorous debate about
whether we need to go beyond
investigation to impeachment no I'm not
trying and just moments ago from The
Oval Office President Trump was fired up
and sounding off on the Democrats
endless investigations I think it's a
disgrace what the Democrats are doing
all they want to do is impede they want
to investigate they want to go fishing
and I watch Bob Muller and they have
nothing these people and clowns the
Democrats had clowns that being laughed
at all over the world and I watched this
morning I watched Nancy Pelosi trying to
get through that with the performance
that robert muller put on where i don't
think he ever read the agreement or the
document and the document said no
collusion they don't even talk about
that so there was no crime they said
well there was no crime but he
obstructed how do you obstruct there's
no crime but actually it was worse than
that because it was a phony crime that
they put on the crime was what they put
on clowns Greg well what else could you
call them I mean you look at the media
right now they expect it they were like
it let's make a deal and they expected a
shiny Corvette behind door number one
and when the curtain pulled back it was
an inflatable doll nothing there for
them and also then you heat then you
know they're saying some of the media
they're saying oh it's a mixed bag right
it's a mixed bag yeah it's a mixed bag
of dog poop cat poop and horse
they can't take the kit as you say Dan
they can't take the El what this was a
great week for were normal people
meaning people not prone to hysterics or
emotional vendetta's that you you you
could watch this with a detached that's
Anna detached observer okay this could
go one way or the other but your whole
life is it hanging on it the way it does
with morning Joe who are having public
nervous breakdowns over this if it went
the other way
we would just get on with our life we'd
go have dinner we'd want you know we'd
feel bad one way or the other
because we support the president we
don't want you know we don't want their
hysteria to be proven to true but now
you see the dams in the media redoubling
their efforts after this failure the
redoubling their efforts for impeachment
so imagine if the hearing was good for
them what would they have done if it's
bad for them this is what they're doing
imagine if it was good for them where
would they have gone I don't know I
don't have porches and tourists the tar
and feather that's right it would have
been pitchforks it's 1,600 and they
tried to frame him they failed they try
to investigate him they failed well I
mean what else can they do
it's a guys ladies have some dignity
please isn't this embarrassing
Kraig they're throwing stuff at the wall
right now okay first it was it was
collusion and that was a hoax then it
was the obstruction hoax now it's money
laundering next it will be felonious MOU
pari in the umpteenth degree piracy on
the open sea jaywalking after men de
aggravated jaywalking we talked about
listen you know you're never supposed to
say in here we talked about in the green
room they say it don't do it I'm doing
it I said the grand can you take the El
from you lost
remember after read my lips the speech
every Republican years later knowledge
big loss shouldn't have said read my
lips and raise taxes the Democrats take
listen I'm giving you free political
advice okay believe me I know what it's
like I lost what I ran for over the El
the case is over he's right you look
like a but I think we should have
accepted that lost
hanging chads and dimpled Chad's and
everything else down there look I'll
chime in on giving some free political
advices as the dem here at the table
this Friday afternoon I have been saying
this till I've been blue in the face the
American people have an investigation
fatigue and when the Democrats go down
these paths where they will not give up
and they are focused more on trying to
get at the president that on important
policy issues that actually help them
win the midterm elections we set
ourselves up to be the greatest
adversary for Trump because we're
playing into his hand we're saying you
know look we all have Trump derangement
syndrome and he's gonna say see see see
and and that distracts from the for the
bigger thing but there are unfortunately
some Democrats that have not gotten the
memo if they don't get it soon the clock
is ticking and we're gonna be in not a
great position to take on Trump in just
a few months in the general election and
again they have so many committees in
the House I mean a thousand committees
and this is just one Oversight Committee
or Intel committee and that's all the
media is focused on it's all the
Democrats are focused on they can't walk
and chew gum at the same time they can't
do infrastructure drug prices health
care asylum can't do anything except
this the problem with the Democrats is
they only talk and listen to other
people who wear makeup for a living no
offense at this table but one thing use
talking about regular folks and that's
one thing that the Democrats and people
on other networks don't understand is
Trump's ability to talk to regular folks
in this country and when he's mad and
he's ranting and raving well you know
what people at home would be too I hold
a grudge I would hold a grudge if
somebody went after me and tried to
destroy me I would be chafed chapped and
white eyed mad about it and followed by
all these snot-nosed brats who hated
Trump his whole life and always wanted
to take him down I would be as furious
as he is and you know what this ferocity
has worked for him the percentage of
people who oppose impeachment has
continued to go up in the last year's
almost what 2/3 people in this country
surveyed and the percentage in favor of
impeachment has has gone down
again he's alright Pelosi is actually
trying to slow Wolcott no matter what
she says well I wonder what the
president could have accomplished if he
didn't have this entire two-year
investigation in the Russia cloud
holding over his head because he had a
poll come out ABC News Washington Post
had him at 40% 47% that is his all-time
high in that poll that was before the
Muller hearing the Fox News poll that
just came out and had approval for the
economy at decades high yeah this is
pretty good stuff right now and now he's
gonna come into a recess where everybody
goes home I think he's really look even
better and this was a heavy anchor
around his neck but what's ironic about
this entire thing too is it's boomerang
on the Democrats and they have no
capacity here for self-reflection even I
think it was David gergan on the other
network nobody watches outside of
airports he said something to the effect
of passively watching I think that's
what they call it he said listen you
know we're not really open to the
Republicans arguments here and they've
been studying this case for a long time
and I think that's why we're unprepared
everybody over there at the airport was
shocked oh my gosh maybe he's right like
we have how to withstand these attacks
about this hoax forever so people at
this table have done the homework
understand without and as you look into
it it's all about the Democrats in
Russia not them I think that was the
first time in the country outside of Fox
News Greg maybe actually heard Joseph
missons name mentioned
sujin GPS named Glenn Simpson's name the
dossier I'd never heard that and I don't
think it's been covered by these hard
news now well it's it I mean it's more
about I guess British collusion isn't it
Russian and I think it's a good question
of the media that credibility of this
endeavor is gone so maybe there's a pill
that's are there to investigate this
investigation because how did that you
know how did this move forward how did
people not see this coming
or did they know that Muller was not
engaged in this investigation and we're
happy that he wasn't engaged because
they were doing other things that would
make a great story for maybe you know a
network I think that's the point because
a lot of people said he had no idea what
was going on in the investigation and it
was run by Clinton donors and Clinton
lawyers so you have to think to yourself
he's being investigated by his political
opponents this was not the nonpartisan
investigation that the American people
were told it was well and again I think
this was the
risk that Democrats took when they
decided to go down this road and put all
their eggs in this basket and call
Muller to testify in front of these
committees because one of two things was
going to happen if you know if he did
not explicitly say yes I would have
charged him with a crime which he kind
of said but didn't say you know they're
gonna lose and so when it comes out that
Muller wasn't as engaged in this process
when he didn't answer so many of the
questions saying I'm not gonna get into
this I'm not gonna get into this I'm not
gonna get into this it it really hurt
the Democrats for putting all their eggs
in this basket which is why I go back to
the point you know who would have never
called a bomb mother to testify he was
on those side Donald Trump because again
he might have done a little bit of
research to figure out that the guy
shouldn't have been sitting in front of
the public he would but again these
Democrats they all talk to themselves
and they go yeah you're doing such a
great job this is gonna be a win all
right and now the investigators are
going to be investigated and for the
first time the White House goes on
offense with regard to these pro